amerika erwacht hierzu diesen wirklich
dramatischen nachrichten dass eben der
präsident an corona virus erkrankt oder
zumindest infiziert ist wie in diesem
land üblich gibt es natürlich auch hier
wahrscheinlich eine gespaltene
reaktionen der amerikanischen menschen
amerikanischen bürger die amerikaner
natürlich insgesamt wünschen niemanden
gesundheitlichen schaden das heißt auch
die trump gegner sind natürlich jetzt
auf der seite jener menschen die
genesungswünsche aussprechen aber
gleichzeitig schwingt hier natürlich
eine große portion häme auch mit weil
wie gesagt donald trump eben jener war
der korona virus verharmlost hat der die
sogar das tragen von masken politisiert
hat der viele ratschläge gegeben hat die
nicht korrekt waren und der immer wieder
gesagt dass das virus sei kein problem
es werde verschwinden und eben andere
menschen würden über reagieren jetzt
natürlich dass er selbst infiziert wird
mit dem corona virus wird hier von
vielen menschen so aufgenommen als
könnte man sagen man hätte es ja
vorhersehen können dass das irgendwann
einmal so kommen wird weil eben der
amerikanische präsident wie viele hier
glauben wenige vorsichtsmaßnahmen
unternommen hat um sich vor infektionen
zu schützen
herbert erklären uns hier einmal bitte
das politische system in den usa sollte
scheint jetzt wirklich ausfallen wer
regiert dann die nachfolge von donald
trumps sollte jetzt wirklich durch die
krankheit schneller schwer in einem
zustand gelangen der das regieren
unmöglich macht dann natürlich wird vize
präsident mike pence
die amtsgeschäfte übernehmen er würde
dann eingeschworen werden
das ganze natürlich ist extrem
dramatisch da ist eben einen monat vor
der wahl passiert
die frage ist jetzt auch wenn donald
trump nicht schwer erkrankt am karower
virus ist die frage natürlich wie es mit
dem wahlkampf auch weitergeht
die es gibt eine weitere tv debatte
diese angesetzt für mitte oktober in
miami aufgrund der allein der
quarantänezeit würde sich das fast nicht
ausgehen dass der präsident der anteil
nehmen könnte es wird erwartet dass
diese debatte und auch die debatte
darauf wahrscheinlich dann abgesagt
werden was mit den wahlkampf dann
passiert sollte tatsächlich wirklich
schwer krank sein oder ins spital
eingeliefert werden auch das steht alles
in den sternen im schlimmsten fall
müsste dann wahrscheinlich mike pence am
wahlzettel stehen bei den beiden wahlen
sollte donald trump war es ihm nicht
möglich sein da wirklich selbst zu
kandidieren und wahlkampf zu führen all
das steht in den sternen so etwas hat es
natürlich so knapp vor den wahlen noch
nie gegeben und amerika hält hier den
abmahn keine frage mehr nachrichten und
breaking news nur bei bet schaut euch
hier das nächste video an und vergiss
nicht zu abonnieren